en el vídeo pasado vimos cómo los
cosenos y los senos de los ángulos se
relacionaban cuando básicamente
reflejábamos el radio terminal a través
del eje x el eje y o ambos ejes lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es ahora
considerar la tangente de estos ángulos
y aquí podemos recordar que la tangente
de teta es igual al seno de teta sobre
el coseno de teta esto quiere decir por
la definición del círculo unitario que
la tangente es la pendiente del radio
terminal recordemos lo que la pendiente
la pendiente es elevación sobre avance
el cambio en el eje vertical sobre el
cambio en el eje horizontal entonces
partiendo el origen cuál es el cambio en
el eje vertical de este rayo el cambio
en el eje vertical es seno de teta y el
cambio en el eje horizontal es coseno de
teta así es que esto va a ser igual al
cambio en y sobre el cambio en x
esto es d
rayo terminal déjame abreviar lo mejor
del rayo terminal es decir la tangente
de teta
beteta sobre coseno beteta o la puedes
ver como la pendiente de este rayo
terminal veamos ahora que otros ángulos
van a tener exactamente la misma
tangente de teta bien este radio de aquí
es co lineal con este otro radio de acá
de hecho si los unes te das cuenta que
forman parte de la misma recta de tal
manera que la tangente de este ángulo en
rosa la tangente de pimas teta la
tangente de teta más me lo puedo poner
teta más propinas teta no importa la
tangente de teta más pi debe de ser
igual basado en este argumento de la
pendiente de la recta a la tangente de
teta debe ser igual a la tangente de
teta déjame ponerlo con el mismo color
tangente de teta así es que estas dos
deben de ser igual si estamos de acuerdo
en que la tangente del ángulo
corresponde a la pendiente del lado
terminal el ángulo tomado
respecto a la parte positiva del eje x
de acuerdo a la convención que hemos
estado usando pero ahora veamos qué es
lo que es la tangente dt está más pi en
términos de seno de teta más pi y coseno
de teta más pi tenemos que tangente
déjame hacer lo mejor en rosa
tangente ese no es rosa
tenemos que tangente de teta más voy a
ponerlo entre paréntesis para evitar
ambigüedad es igual a seno de teta más
para seno de t está más dividido entre
coseno de tettamanti y en el vídeo
anterior establecimos que seno de
tettamanti es igual a en menos seno de
teta
así es que esto es igual a menos seno de
teta y coseno detectan más pi es igual a
menos coseno de teta así es que este es
igual a menos coseno de teta menos entre
menos es más y se no detectan entre
coseno de teta es igual a la tangente de
teta si es que esto es igual la tangente
de teta la igualdad si se cumple ahora
qué pasa con los puntos más bien los
rayos terminales que se encuentran aquí
que se encuentran que pasa con las
tangentes de estos ángulos
pensemos en este punto
cuál es la tangente de menos theta la
tangente menos teta sabemos que es seno
de menos de está dividido entre coseno
de - teta ahora bien se 9 - teta ya
vimos que es menos seno de teta aquí lo
tenemos
se mueven ustedes la coordenada en irak
y que es menos esta coordenada en menos
seno de teta así es que esto es menos de
90 y cose 9 menos teta las coordenadas
en x aquí son iguales es igual a coseno
de teta de tal manera que esto es igual
entonces a menos seno de t está dividido
entre coseno de teta seno ett / coseno
ett están gente de tetas y es que esto
es igual a menos tangente de teta y aquí
lo podemos ver si tomamos el negativo
del ángulo vamos a obtener el negativo
de la tangente y esto es porque cambia
el signo del numerador cambia el signo
del seno mientras que el signo del
denominador
así es que tan gente de menos teta es
igual a menos tangente de teta ahora que
sucede con este punto que tenemos aquí
aquí en relación al ángulo teta estamos
considerando el ángulo y menos de eta
tenemos que la tangente de pi - teta la
tangente de pi menos teta es igual al
seno de pi menos te está dividido entre
el coseno de pi menos de eta y se 9
menos de está ya vimos que es igual a
seno de teta seno de eta
ambas tienen la misma coordenada en g
así es que esto es igual a seno de teta
y coseno de pi menos teta que es la
coordenada en x es menos coste no
detecta jose 9 primeros tests menos 12 9
teta
así es que esto es igual de 9 teta sobre
menos coseno etc esto es igual a menos
tangente de teta lo cual hace sentido
este rayo tiene que tener la misma
y que este rayo que este rayo de aquí es
decir el valor de la pendiente de esta
recta corresponde a menos menos la
tangente de teta y aquí lo puedes ver si
tomamos estas dos rectas que son la
combinación de los rayos estas dos
rectas tienen la misma pendiente con
signo opuesto una es la imagen especular
de la otra a través del eje x así es que
hemos visto que si tomas un ángulo y
sumas pía el ángulo la tangente no va a
cambiar porque vas a estar básicamente
sobre la misma línea al tomar un ángulo
de ti radiales o 180 grados va a ser en
dirección opuesta pero la pendiente del
rayo no va a cambiar así es que la
tangente de teta es lo mismo que la
tangente de teta más p pero si tomas el
opuesto del ángulo entonces vas a tener
menos la tangente del ángulo o si llegas
a este punto
al tomar y menos el ángulo al tomar y
menos el ángulo en este caso también vas
a obtener menos
gente del ángulo espero que hayas
encontrado esto interesante realmente es
muy útil cuando estás trabajando
problemas de trigonometría o estás
tratando de mostrar algunas identidades
aunque de hecho aquí hemos probado
algunas identidades pero lo que es
realmente útil es pensar en estas
simetrías y reflexiones que se dan en el
círculo unitario